ALL WITH
ONE FRANCHISE IS ABSOLUTELY, NO
BACKSTROM EITHER.
HE HASN'T PLAYED THE GAME ALL TE
THE PUCK ENTERS THE ZONE,HEN GE.
THAT WAS JUSTIN SCHULTZ.
EXCUSE ME, IT W
ZONE SO IN OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
RUSH FOR BACK.
MANSON'S SHOP GOT THROUGH AND HA
SLIDE PASS.OW.
McTAVISH IS IMMEDIATELY
ENGAGED AGAIN BY ANES IT
AND GIVES IT UP.
TRYING TO GET IT BACK TO HIM WAS
HENRIQUE SECONDS
HERE OF THE SECOND PERIOD.
FOWLER COMES UP WITH A T T A TW.
LINE.
NOW IT IS IN THE WAS BY
PILON.
POINT IS OPOPAND IT'S GOING TO S
GOAL.URNS.
HIS SHOT DEFLECTED WIDE.
SHATTENKIRK BACKHANDS IT AROUNDE
BACKHAND AER
GETZLAF SHOVELS AN END TO PURSUE
IT IS VAN
4 MINUTES REMAINING IN
REGULATION.
THE DUCKS LEAD DEAL.
>> John: DEFLECTED IT IN.
NUDGES IT BEHIND THE IS G G CAPE
FACE-OFF QUESTION MIKE GETZLAF
HASS
WHO STARTS WITH POSSESSIORAL ZO.
THE DUCKS WOULD LIKE TO MINUTE S
ZEGRAS NEARLY COUGHS IT UP AS HE